hello i'm wolfgang puck and today i'm
gonna show you how to make a delicious
mushroom risotto if you know the
technique you can do it just as well as
me
the most important part is the rice now
this is canaroli rice it comes from
northern italy which is just perfect for
risotto because it makes the risotto
really creamy let me show you how to
chop an onion you have the root here
and the stem on this side so we cut the
stem off but we leave a little bit of
the root to hold it together and then
you slice it just like i do and then one
time in half and look how easy
and another quick technique hold it with
your fingers down here
and then we chop
see that up and down
maybe you wonder what we do with garlic
i just smash it see the cloves here
like this
one two
three just go like that and you're done
when you make a stock at home it really
depends if you make a chicken stock or a
vegetable stock or a fish stock a fish
dog we only cook for 45 minutes
vegetable stock maybe for an hour
chicken or beef stock maybe for five
hours we don't throw anything away this
onion leftover which i didn't chop put
it in my stock here still get the flavor
these are three mushrooms you can find
in any store these days
so we cut off the stem
and put it in our stock this one the
same root here we're gonna cut it off
just like this and put it in our stock
see that the shiitake mushroom the stems
are really tough so in the stock they go
i love the flavor of the cheetah cape
but just the cap the best way to clean
mushrooms use a wet towel and you wipe
up
the top we have this clamshell mushrooms
and just
give the stock a lot of flavor now we're
gonna turn up the heat a little bit and
let it simmer slowly when i go to the
farmer's market if i find peas i find
asparagus or great carrots any
vegetables you like you can use for
risotto risotto is a great flavor
carrier so you can actually
use whatever you like now we have the
garlic we have the onions we're gonna
put about three tablespoon of olive oil
in our pan i have a great sous chef or
he could be a chef anywhere in any
restaurant in any hotel this is andrew
andrew is working with me how many years
ten to twelve at least we are heating up
the olive oil through the garlic
the onions
and did already some chopping for me
here i can add a little bit i don't want
to make him feel bad and hurt his
feelings it's just as good if not better
than mine
it smells already if you do that at home
and you have guests over naturally the
guests have to wait for the rice the
rice does not wait for the guests we
don't want to brown the onions just cook
them until they're glossy like i do here
and then we're gonna add the rice
we're gonna glaze the rice here with the
olive oil the onion and the garlic now
when i cook at home they'll always have
a glass of wine for me too so cheers
just use the same vinyl drink also for
your cooking you can see the rice is
perfectly glazed here a little wine
about half a cup is enough
good you can measure at home but you
know i did that a few times already in
my life even i look so young but i did
it many times i grew up eating a lot of
rice in southern austria but never
really risotto the first time a good
customer of ours wanted to have risotto
in his house i did a party and i said
okay i bring five pounds of rice and was
maybe for 20 people and i get a big pot
i started to make the risotto and you
know once you add the liquid the stock
to it it grows it grows i didn't know
what to do anymore i threw half of it
into the sink it clogged up the sink i
had my chef underneath and unclogging
the pipes of the sink to be able to cook
so when you make risotto
you don't need a lot i also like it as
an appetizer i cook the rice with the
wine until the wine is completely
evaporated the important part of the
wine is to give the food balance the
acidity of the wine gives the food
balance our stock is ready here hmm i
can smell
the freshness of the mushrooms
i'm gonna put about two ladle fulls of
stock in here and we're gonna start
cooking the risotto we add the stock a
little at the time like half a cup to a
cup at the time if you add everything at
once you're gonna have a soup and you
don't know how much you need the
stirring really helps to remove the
starch from the outside of the rice and
make your risotto nice and creamy it
takes about 20 minutes to make a risotto
so you can go from a to c in 20 minutes
as long as you have your measurements
ready what is the amazon plus to get
everything ready so all you have to do
is cook my rice is cooking along here so
i'm gonna add a little more of the stock
i have my risotto on about a medium heat
but just be sure that it cooks gently
we're gonna cook our mushrooms i always
start with olive oil first because if i
would add butter in here it might burn
it so the olive oil i'm now gonna add
maybe a tablespoon of butter here okay
and we're gonna continue adding stock to
our rice
now i'm gonna saute the mushroom you
know onion or shallots and garlic for
mushroom is perfect i always use fresh
ground pepper because it makes
everything taste so much better it has
more power it's spicier but is the aroma
of the pepper make everything smell
better and taste better my mushrooms are
pretty dry in here so what do i gonna do
i'm gonna add a little bit of my stock
it will steam it up and i can saute my
mushroom perfectly often people say oh
the risotto will cook by itself no you
have to stay next to it and steal it
constantly but it's a lot of fun you can
do it with your children at home they
learn how to make it you saute your
onion your garlic put the rice in a
little wine if you have if you don't
like wine and put a little white white
vinegar a few tablespoons that way you
have the right balance and then just
continue stirring the rice i use some
sea salt here and don't add too much at
the beginning i love pepper my risotto
is always a little peppery i always tell
people you buy the best ingredients and
then try not to screw them up so that's
so simple i'm gonna add a little more
stock
okay and i think my mushrooms are done
i'm gonna turn the fire off here i'm
gonna take about half of my mushrooms
and i'm gonna blend them by planting
some of your mushrooms will give the
risotto creaminess but also extra
flavors even if you're a vegan you make
the risotto with the mushrooms in like
that it's gonna be perfectly creamy you
don't need butter and cheese
perfect
mmm smells delicious and it [ __ ] up my
lenses too but it's good now we're gonna
add our mushroom puree here look at that
so it's totally creamy mushrooms we are
gonna taste my rice it might be on maybe
a little more
getting there
even if you have a steak a chicken
breast or some fresh meat make a
mushroom puree that's magic we stir it
constantly so that way it doesn't burn
it does not touch to the bottom also
it's important to make the risotto
really creamy let's taste one more time
i would say we are two minutes away i'm
gonna add a little more stock to it now
i'm gonna add peas to it for color but
also for taste because the peas are very
sweet i always put hot food on hot
plates it's very important you don't
want to put hot food on a cold plate the
food will get cold so you put your
plates in the oven that way they are
nice and warm we love butter and we love
parmesan cheese that makes everything
taste better butter here i'm gonna turn
the stove to low
and incorporate the butter butter fat
emulsifies the liquid even more so with
the starch so you even get more
creaminess into your risotto parmesan
very important i always buy a chunk of
parmesan and then grate it freshly into
my risotto don't buy the one which is
already grated in little plastic bags in
the supermarket because they lose use
all the leftovers they can't use
in chunks parmesan has the umami flavor
it makes everything taste better so be
generous with the parmesan we call it a
microplane it is a great grater just be
careful when you grate it maybe even use
a towel so that way you don't grate your
fingers in there i'm gonna turn off the
heat now stir in the parmesan and we're
gonna taste it one more time let's taste
it and you taste it andrew
what do you think
i think the rice is perfect it's perfect
maybe a little little all right put a
little salt
not too much because i have high blood
pressure you want to be sure when you
cook a risotto it's not like a porridge
should have just a little bite to it so
that the grains are not mushy i'm gonna
taste it how it goes with my chardonnay
here
a good rich chardonnay or a pinot is a
perfect accompaniment for your risotto
if the guests are not seated right away
be sure stop your risotto
and in case your risotto gets to take a
little bit more stock you want the
risotto bean nice and creamy my last
taste
amazing now i'm gonna show you how to
plate it we have our warm plate here
put it in the center
as much or as little as you want you
know if you just eat the risotto like
for me at home with my children with my
wife we just cooked a risotto and that's
our dinner maybe a salad on the side but
you can have a grilled chicken breast
whatever you like i remember i did the
academy award once i made a truffle
risotto and then served it with a
chicken breast look on my plate here
that is sort of consistency should be if
you move it
the risotto should be able to move so it
flattens out on our plate here see that
i have my mushrooms here
a spoonful in the center and again more
parmesan
okay we have a little fresh herbs chives
parsley whatever you like you can chop
it up sprinkle it over and we'll found
pea tenders because i have peas in here
already
so we're going to add a little peat
handle so to make it look good you know
we eat with our eyes first so it's
really important to make the
presentation really beautiful but you
don't have to do a lot you can go to the
farmer's market or to your local market
and find things like bee dandel also
edible flowers take off the petals
and then you sprinkle a few on it so now
all of a sudden it looks like spring or
summer now you know how to make the
perfect risotto just don't open a
restaurant next to spago because i won't
like you if you do that andrew what do
you think it's gorgeous chef all the
different colors but the taste is the
most important part and a few mushrooms
in your first bite
and now you know how to make a great
risotto until next time we are gonna
show you more but you also can watch my
documentary on disney plus it's called
wolfgang
[Music]
you